in this video we're going to talk about
three potential AC T problems that you
might encounter on that next AC T that
you take so let's jump into this video
let's talk about three questions that
can boost your score when you take that
test starting with number one how many
distinct permutations are there of the
letters in the word algebra okay so what
we want to do when we talk about
permutations is how many different ways
can we rearrange those letters so that
we can get a different word okay using
all the letters so go ahead and pause
the video see if you can do that on your
own
but what I would do if I was tackling
this problem is I would think about you
know how many letters are there one two
three four five six seven letters okay
now when you order objects okay you can
think about this formula and a factorial
and what the factorial means is that you
take whatever this n value is which in
this case it's seven since there's seven
letters and you multiply down to one and
the reason we're doing that is because
you know if you look at the seven
letters in the word algebra one two
three four five six seven
how many choices are there for this
first letter well there's seven right if
you put them in a hat and you mix them
up how many ways could you pick a letter
will it be seven different letters in
that hat that you could pick out right
but then once you picks it pick that
letter out that first one how many are
there going to be for the second grab
right well there's going to be six and
then after that there's maybe five four
three two one right and so we're doing
is we're multiplying those together to
find out the total number of you know
ways that you could draw off these seven
letters the only problem though is is
that you see how there's two A's okay in
algebra so if I was to put the a over
here and over here or switch them it
would still look like the same word
algebra right so what we have to do is
we have to divide out two factorial
because there's two ways of placing
those A's and you wouldn't really
realize that it's a different word so we
have to divide out those multiplicities
or those duplicates so that's how you
would do that problem now I'll just give
you another example similar this one in
case you want to see a more general
example say for example we took the word
Mississippi okay this is a common
example M is s is s I P
I there's eleven letters here this
allows you know eleven factorial
different ways of arranging those
letters right 11 10 9 8 all the way down
to 1 but notice how we have 4 asses so
we're going to divide out 4 factorial
we've got 2 peas we're going to divide
out 2 factorial and we have 4 eyes so
we're going to divide out 4 factorial
and again the reason that we're doing
this is because 4 times 3 times 2 times
1 is actually 24 and there's 24
different ways that you could rearrange
those s's so for example that was to put
like s here s here like kind of
rearranging but keep them in these same
4 places right move them around it would
still look like the word of Mississippi
so what we want to do is we want to
divide out those duplicates or multiple
multiples you would say all right so
that's question number one definitely
something helpful to remember so let's
go to number two this one says solve for
X and they give us this equation ok so
what do you think go ahead and pause the
video see if you can do this one on your
own
we've got 4 to the 2x minus 3 equals
1/16 to the X power all right so you
might be thinking logarithms you might
be thinking our rules of exponents
different things might be going through
your mind right now
but I'll show you the key in this
problem and that's to get the same base
on both sides of the equation so in this
case when we look at 4 and we look at
1/16 what do they have in common well we
can do this a couple different ways but
1/16 is really like 4 to the negative 2
ok now why negative well 4 squared is 16
but that negative exponent tells us to
take the reciprocal flip it over right
so that's how we get to 1/16 and it's
all raised to the X power now when you
have a power to a power what do you do
you multiply so you might want to review
your rules of exponents if some of this
seems challenging to you but they
definitely test you on exponent rules on
the AC T so now the 4 to the 2x minus 3
I'm just going to bring that down on the
left side of our equation okay now
notice what we've got here we've got
base for base 4 right they have the same
base so if the bases are the same what
we can do is we can set those exponents
equal to one another so the only way the
left side and the right side are gonna
be equal if the bases are the same as if
the powers are the same so let's go
ahead and solve this
now 2 X minus 3 is equal to negative 2 X
let's say I'm going to subtract 2x from
both sides of the equation right so
we've got negative 3 equals negative 4 X
I'm going to divide both sides by
negative 4 right so X is equal to 3/4 so
that's the answer to that problem and
again you know with the acct it's
multiple choice so you can always take
you know ABCDE the multiple choice
answers put them in and check it's just
that some of these problems are going to
be easier if you just know the
techniques that I'm showing you here
then having to back substitute and try
to check each individual choice so
that's one two we've got one more
example but Before we jump into that
last example if you're preparing for the
AC T and you want additional help you
like the way that I teach my teaching
style and so forth I've got a huge AC
t-- math review video course it goes
through 65 concepts that are important
to know for the AC t we go through a
number of examples a lot of students
have taken the courses already and
reported back that they've been very
helpful and I'm sure it'll help you too
so go ahead and check out those courses
let's get into the last example number 3
it says which of the following is
equivalent to 36 x squared plus 25 so
you can see I've written down a few
multiple choice answers and again you
know your option is always to work
backwards you know you could multiply
these together and see which one of
these works so maybe we'll go ahead and
take a look at some of these just to see
how that would be so for the first one
you can see this is a binomial times a
binomial and if you recognize this this
is a sum and difference pattern right
you're adding and subtracting but the
terms are the same so there's a shortcut
to this but we'll just do the
distributive property so distribute
that's going to give us what 36 x
squared this is going to give us plus
30x and then we distribute the negative
5 we get negative 30x right and negative
5 times 5 is negative 25 so you can see
those are cancelling and we're left with
36 x squared minus 25 not plus 25 right
so we're close but not quite there right
ok let's look at letter B so for letter
B same idea I'm gonna take 6x times 6x
which is 36
squared 6x x 5y 5 I am sorry is a 30-i X
and then the inside gives us negative 30
iakhs right and then the last in the
last gives us negative 25 I squared now
remember on the AC T there's oftentimes
an imaginary question or complex number
type question a question involving I and
remember I represents what the square
root of negative 1 I squared is equal to
negative 1 so these are two things that
you want to know and memorize for the AC
T so I squared is negative 1 so if I put
in negative 1 for I squared here that's
a negative 1 times a negative 25 which
those two negatives are gonna cancel and
give us a positive 25 the 30 I X and
negative 30 i X cancel so you can see
we're getting 36 x squared plus 25 you
can see we've got a match
and so it's going to be letter B but I
want to just show you something real
quick here about factoring a sum of two
squares we learn about how to factor a
difference of two squares and that's
definitely important for the AC T
remember a squared minus B squared we
factor this as a plus B a minus B right
but if we've got a squared plus B
squared we factor it like this a plus bi
times a minus bi and you can verify that
by foiling this out or doing the
distributive property twice and you'll
see that you get back the original here
but either case like I said you can work
backwards but sometimes it's good to
know these little shortcuts about in
this case factoring a sum of two squares
so I hope this video really helps you
get a few more questions right on the AC
T again check out that course I think
that'll really help you and I look
forward to seeing the future videos I'll
talk to you soon